did you write the music first or the
words first
together the same time which is very
typical for me
but uh just the way it opens like how
you know intensity of openings you ever
think about like what the first few
seconds sound like is that something
that um like when you imagine a song
is it the opening you imagine
no it's kind of a it's just a
i never think opening i never think
final i think
soundscape of how i'm feeling right now
so it could be the middle of the song
for all i know when i'm you know when
i'm when i'm doing that but
my process for me is very much lyrics
and melody and music
really come at the same time like i
by the same time i mean i'm
i'm uh as i'm expressing maybe
you know i'm feeling like
[Music]
like it's not that simple but it's like
i'll i'll hear it like it's like here's
all the orchestra and you're kind of
just pressing all the buttons at once
and
melody and my voice is just one of those
instruments you know i mean it's just
utilizing one instrument so you're
seeing the landscape and that landscape
includes melody includes percussion
lyrics yeah a little bit or literally
will be words to begin with like a word
here and there like i'll be like
you know i'm like what's a word that i'm
thinking of when i'm feeling this
soundscape and
i always create
with no theme in mind i'm never
for for better of worse just my process
is i'm sitting down
and i'm writing a journal entry simple
as that it's like when you sit down to
write a journal entry are you sitting
down and you're like okay i've had all
these words here that i'm going to put
on the page and i'm going to order it in
this way and my theme for my journal
entry today is going to be this maybe
some people do but i don't my journal
entry is
i don't know what i'm going to say oh
how was today well man today was this
and i'm feeling this and now that i
think about that i'm really angry about
that that hurt my feelings when this
you're like you're formulating it as you
go and that's the joy of it and for me
that's what music is
so i sit down
not thinking hey i've been wanting to
write a song that has a hard beat or
i've been wanting to write a song that's
anthemic or i've been wanting to write a
song that's it's like how am i feeling
right now and it's joyful with is it
feeling joyful to you or is it struggle
because you just made it sound like it's
i think joyful
yeah fulfilling is the word i was kind
of looking for but there was there's a
lot of artists talk about really strong
like you talk about writers cathartic
that's the word
it feels like
having a good moment with a therapist
where you're like
okay
i'm expressing this thing that i just
need to express for whatever reason i
need to express this the majority of the
songs i write for the record are never
heard i write over a hundred songs a
year i release
20 songs every three years
so
i don't know what's that percent 20 out
of 300 come on lex
less than 10 less than 10 percent
yeah um
anyway so it's and then like getting
together with the band and like getting
them selected down is really what uh the
process so you're really writing
a song per one to three days kind of
maybe a song that you can't quite figure
out the puzzle of that's going to last a
little a little longer
is it worth it for every idea yeah you
finish every idea i do i finish every
idea so it's not just like laying
completely unfinished i could open my
computer for you right now and i would
show you
hundreds and hundreds of songs that you
would listen to and think
that sounds like a song it's like
there's rhythm there's melody there's
multiple instruments there's lyrics like
i
it's the same thing as is for coding for
me which is music which is yeah i can't
walk away until i've completed it but
it's finished my well finished is it
finished yeah it sounds like a song i
certainly do a lot more with it after
with the band where we should pull it
all apart but it's a song it'll be like
you know it's you'll listen to it and
say okay that was a song i get
you understand what
what it is for sure do you think
this is a painful question from a fan
perspective
do you think there's
genius
on your computer that you walked away
from that you just didn't notice it
like do you think there's truly great
songs that you've written
that you just
didn't notice how great they are i i
think
greatness is something that i feel i'm
i'm
i i don't feel like i've achieved
greatness genuine i'm not saying that to
you in a way of like humility michael
jordan
no genuinely i feel like i
am on a journey right now
to find who i am and i'm 34 and it's
like
i don't even i i haven't begun that
journey i feel like i'm just starting
that
but that being said
i certainly
don't know
the right answer to what songs are you
know beloved or good to the masses like
imagine dragons is such a massive entity
it's like
there have been a i will say this there
are a couple times where i fought really
hard to decide on the single
really hard
or i always fight for what goes on the
record always i always put the record
together and that's the record that i
wanted to be and me and the guys come up
with that and it's nobody else has
influence no manager no label
the single
everybody wants to have a saying your
label wants to have a say in it your
manager wants to have a say in it
and i have
fought really hard over that and i've
been wrong before and i've been right
before
um but as far as songs that i haven't
put out
i mean
you can imagine so many songs you think
you think of so many beatles songs
that are like some of their grace while
my guitar gently weeps right
let me i'm trying to imagine
weird sounding not that interesting
possibly songs the majority of what we
honestly
they may it may be
our best stuff is that we don't put out
for instance because our band is such a
it's such a complex question i really
don't know actually i don't know maybe
one day i'll die and people will look
and be like i hated imagine dragons but
now i listen to that song i really like
that i wish they would put that out or
maybe they'll be like oh this all sounds
like [ __ ] i don't really know
um well that's that's sorry it is a
tragic thing that's why i asked it which
is like
there could be some
[Music]
great incredible things that
that will take you a long time to
rediscover to realize how great they are
and it's just it's also the tragic
aspect of being an artist is you don't
know
if you get fame or all that kind of
stuff you don't know what's going to
really move people because ultimately
what you want
is to
to connect with people and you don't
know what that's going to be
it's hard i mean to me it's
to me it's tragic just as a fan of yours
to see maybe i wonder if there's like
incredible stuff there just as it is
tragic to see great artists throughout
history who didn't get recognition until
they died
it's like
because they basically held on
you know uh
franz kafka was extremely self-critical
a lot of these folks had an idea of
what's good and not and they were wrong
right
they were gene they had genius
they weren't entirely wrong because they
became sufficiently popular but
it's interesting i try to genuinely to
release the songs that move me the most
got it i'll say that you're an audience
you're your own audience yeah i try to
put out the songs that make me feel
the most like i fee i feel that that's
my only gauge because it's so subjective
of like what is good what's this
nobody knows the song the masses are
gonna like nobody knows that formula
nobody knows it so for me it's always
what makes me feel something one of the
main lessons rick rubin taught me when
we worked with him on this record was he
would say
he would his his
main point that he would continually
bring up when like
because he's not the type person be like
that's a bad song or that's good it's
just not who rick rubin is it's more
like there's more nuance to it he would
say
i don't really believe you on that song
that's what he would say he would say
and i knew that was like that song's a
no-go
you